comme un pied de nez aux confiné en
toute quiétude
ces oiseaux profite pleinement de la
plage du calme qui y règne de la douceur
des vagues et d'une petite brise au
passage le temps est clair et lumineux
malgré un temps sec la nature respire
abeilles oiseaux et libellules dans ce
même dans les zones urbaines
les hommes occupent beaucoup moins
l'espace et donc d'aller les animaux
occupent l'espace qui n'est plus occupé
par l'homme
à fort de france par exemple pour ne
citer que cet exemple mais de façon
générale dans toutes les agglomérations
en martinique beaucoup d'administrés fin
de voilà deux concitoyens indique voir
deux des libellules par exemple ou des
colibris ce qu'ils avaient de très
rarement l'occasion de voir sur leur
balcon voir qu'il n'avait plus vu depuis
plusieurs depuis plusieurs années et
dont concert on sent bien qu'il ya
quelque chose qui est en train de
changer donc les animaux bien entendu
étant beaucoup moins stressé étant
beaucoup moins j'ai envie de repousser
vers les marges mais occupent l'espace
qui normalement est le leur moins de
pollution sonore atmosphérique ou
lumineuses beaucoup moins d'avions moins
de circulation et donc moins d'émissions
de particules fines selon madininair la
baisse des polluants et spectaculaire
par exemple pour les oxydes d'azoté qui
sont le polluant je le rappelle le plus
représentatif de la circulation
automobile et bien tous ces oxydes d
azote la baisse est de quasiment 90% en
milieu urbain est quasiment de 70% en
milieu trafic donc vraiment une vision
très très flagrante des choses ensuite
pour les particules c'est un peu la même
chose avec notamment les particules les
plus fines qui ont également décès d'une
trentaine de pour cent et c'est la même
chose pour les autres polluants
classiques habituels de l'activité
humaine et la brume de sable
habituellement chez nous entre février
et la mi octobre on a une année très
particulière en termes de
de météo sur le mois de mars concernant
les bandes de sable puisqu'on a constaté
une remontée de ses brumes de sable de
particules désertique jusqu au milieu de
l'europe d'ailleurs la semaine dernière
la normandie avait un certain nombre de
dépassements de seuil
donc on a un phénomène un peu
particulier sur 20 ans d'historique de
madininair c'était arrivé de manière
très très rare oui assurément notre
nature se porte mieux depuis le début du
confinement
c'est dire l'empreinte de l'homme sur la
nature et les dégâts qu'il provoque
aujourd'hui nous nous rendons compte que
nous avons besoin de la nature mais elle
n'a pas forcément besoin de nous je
pense que c'est une vraie leçon
d'humilité ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment dramatique sur le plan
sanitaire
c'est dramatique sur le plan humain mais
c'est une vraie vraie leçon d'humilité
et je crois qu'il faut que nous en
tirions quelque chose il faut qu'après
le la phase 2 fin lors du déconfinement
que nous ayons encore en mémoire le fait
que nous formons tous si vous voulez
nous nous faisons partie de l'écosystème
et que cet écosystème pour en faire
partie et pour véritablement j'ai envie
de dire en être digne il faut
véritablement que nous y participions
honnêtement et dignement mais sans
forcément vouloir le dominer la servir
la nature à la fois forte et si fragile
nous donne des leçons mais serons-nous
les retenir